live chair
right
well
welcome everybody to this meeting of the
harbour board
uh first of all
i would like to comment on last tuesday
evening where counselor james and myself
uh went as passengers on the pilot boat
to
see the boat which had just been loaded
with clay out of the biddeford harbor
most
interesting
but i would personally
like to comment on the quality of our
staff and the work they do
the pilot and his two right-hand man is
coxen and bosun
the way they dealt with the mata is most
impressive
they
indicated to us that we were lucky we
were on a nice
still evening
and i can fully sympathize with them
what it would be like
when it was blowing a hooli in there
but
the quality of staff we have are in my
opinion brilliant
and i would like to thank them for
taking us on board
and
if any members of the council
ever get the opportunity to do this trip
i would advise them to do it
because they will really learn
what goes on in the running of the
harbor at biddeford
councillor james would you add anything
to that yeah i was just going to come in
then bob and say
yes it was a marvelous evening the staff
were brilliant
um i think it was kelly who told me off
for being alongside the barrier but
never mind um but the professionalism of
all the staff was brilliant and i do as
you say commend their work and fully
support them and uh
yeah i've already inquired about a new
pilot boat
right we moved now on to the formal
agenda number one apologies for absence
yes chair two apologies councillor
christie and mr tim gibbs
thank you
uh item two the minutes of the uh
last meeting which
was held on
the
oh
24th of june
i will read from
the bottom page numbers
3
4
5 and 6.
are we happy that they're true correct
record
yep i propose
thank you there's uh mr hardaker can you
second it
okay second uh unfortunately council
here because you know uh
uh i was not at the last meeting because
of the stupidity of zoom
we were both missing so
we'll have to take them as read
any questions on them or comments
no i'm fine i went through them this
morning i'm fine
right thank you
we moved to item three the action list
uh minute number
eight um
anyone wishing to comment
i'm sorry i've not got the agenda in
front of me bob so
oh right um
estuary sampling
um
it's still in alliance as i understand
it
by virtue of the problems we have with
harbormaster is that correct richard
uh yes i don't know if paul wants to the
interim half of master wants to give a
brief update of where we are we've
slightly progressed
um
we slightly progressed uh looking into
this
you know it's it's a an action that's
been
on the uh action list for a long long
time so for for my aim is either it is a
you know we are going to look into this
and really make it a serious project or
we decide that it's not viable to do but
um
paul do you just want to give a brief
update on delighted yes do you please
yeah do please stop me if i start go
rambling too much that the situation is
this is that the um 1925 biddeford
harbor uh
means that the harbor authority owns the
seabed from the new bridge affected to
the old bridge
and is licensed or is able to sell that
um
for capital gain
the only action that we have to do in
order to to be able to commercially
exploit that that seabed is to
uh prove to the uh marine management
organization that it is uninfected un
contaminated uh mr glover mr anthony
glover approached us a few months ago to
say he was interested in trying to uh
use
to commercially work that that part of
the biddeford harbor act uh i looked at
it discussed it with with mr hayes and
we decided it was a at least worth
looking at it uh mr glover has taken
samples of the seabed uh in the
competent harbour in the uh statutory
harbor authority area and sent them away
to the mmo and we're waiting from their
reaction back what i've said to mr
glover is that
before we even come anywhere near the
harbour board uh with any sort of
decision or thoughts is that we must
have he must have a plan about how he's
going to do it uh how he's going to
execute it what the effects would be in
terms of using as a town key to land a
ton of sand or
right up to
slightly larger prospects for the
harbour board then for them that to be
presented to the harbour board for the
harbour board to make a decision on it
and then after that the process with the
mmo consenting would take place so um
while mr hayes is actually right it it's
progressing and there is uh somebody
actually interested in using the com the
harbour commercially um i'm my
experience with the mmo in my previous
lives at dover and elsewhere is that it
generally takes twice as long as you
think it's going to so i would hope by
the time we come back to the next
harbour board meeting would at least
have the samples back and an outline way
ahead to to put before you for approval
or not
proper job thank you
next one i got number 37
storage ideas for the harbor
now just coupling this together
uh i think it's one for rich dude
as we sailed up the estuary on tuesday
night
looking across at brunswick wharf
which we've just sold
then there's our car park then there
seems to be a gap
before you come to the
house center
and we wondered who owned that and if
any use could be made of it
chair as as far as i'm aware that is all
part of the brunswick development that's
just been sold off you were talking next
to the wooden surgery the
yeah there's a way
that's all part of the brunswick
development and will be developed in
time
right
anything else on the storage ideas
no we
chair we've met with um
nigel evans um
as yourself when we
yourself and i went up there and met
with him and discussed that and the the
issues of so the types of material that
we're bringing on would need covered
storage and unfortunately a bit of a key
harbor area
isn't suitable for that type of building
um so
it is difficult it is difficult and i'm
not sure how where where further we can
go with this one at the moment um
bearing in mind brunswick
um
it was never an auction that side of the
river anyway
no
right
next one i have running with it
as we went down the estuary
one looked at your neatly parked waste
vehicles
is that site such the key such
that it could ever be used for loading
unloading storing
um that's something that i would discuss
with the economic development team i'm
with sean um
but
i'm not sure that the even with the
berth dug out there that the size of
ship would be able to access it today
without great excavation but likewise
the access and egress roads you know in
into that site are limited as well
um
but it's something if you wish as the
chair to be progressed then you know we
could at least
look at that
now that we've purchased the site
yeah
um
yes
i think
so would i would i uh is it okay if i
just offer an opinion um again i think
richard is absolutely right that the
issue is and as we discussed on the
river the other evening the issue is is
not
the uh viability of the harbour it's
actually the viability of the cargo that
goes out through as as we've discussed
um the key down at apple door um
has been used previously and i've i've
spoken to the the the john pav the elder
john pav's uh dad who who was coxing the
heart the pilot launch for for a number
of years there used to be vessels that
go in there but richard is absolutely
right
again the issue arises not from the
viability of the key but the access to
it for
signifi large enough trucks to deliver
cargo and storing it but um
gosh anything that anything
might be worth looking at but i uh again
i'd i i've only been past it i've never
looked at it seriously other than going
oh there are richards trucks
right well we have been looking at
options to what to do with that site and
we have had some approaches there's no
reason that's not raised as an option
okay
i mean strictly speaking and sorry to
sound like a sea lawyer um but of course
it is outside the statutory harbour area
of biddeford harbor uh it is within
obviously it's within it's a torrid
district council piece of land
but strictly speaking the harbour or the
water
that that part of the water belongs to
the queen i don't suppose for a moment
if they viable um
a business plan was put together the
crown of state would bite our arms off
to say yes thank you very much but
strictly speaking below the new bridge
it's not part of our stasis harbor
authority authority area we don't have
any
uh maritime uh sway there or we don't
have very much maritime sway if that
makes sense
we do lose we do lease the foreshore
don't we
yes we do
yeah
and my legal legal knowledge about the
niceties of whether it's outside of
statutory harbor earth area whether it's
a lease for sure and how that would work
is is probably a little bit sketchy we
probably need to take um
a qualified legal advice rather than me
my harbour mastering advice
yeah
fair enough
any more on that mr chairman
yep
um
are we talking about hanson's wharf now
because
isn't that
so badly silted up it would cost an
absolute
fortune to to dredge it if there was any
proposal
not if you're selling the dredge dredge
materials at a pound a ton which is it's
prime sand sorry sorry too i beg your
pardon i i haven't stepped on your toes
there but the um the sand in the river
you can sell it a pound a ton
is it sand or mud
i think it's sand there isn't it i might
be wrong
well most of it will be sand that uh
if my recollections are right of c when
the arc od and the arco dart are
discharged
uh of putting i think most of it will be
sand would wouldn't the cost of dredging
be uh
it'd be astronomical wouldn't it it
wouldn't be a viable proposition
could i just say that we purchased that
site with the aim of the fact that it
presented us with a dockside site
and we are looking at all sorts of
options so there's no reason
that comes out this committee doesn't go
forward absolutely
sure mr puddy would like to come in
yeah
yeah um chair i'm just a bit confused
here are we talking about the hansen
site or the evans site
the the the one further down where the
recycling vehicles are
the evidence
yeah okay so i mean the hansen site
obviously has very good access and what
um
um the the restriction only really
occurs on that really sharp bend just
before the entrance to the site so
is there a potential
for creating a new entrance um for for
future use
which would really bring that site back
into use and certainly um
the um the vessels that did use the site
the the arco
sandvik vessels were of the size of the
um the commercial trading ships
chair do you wish me to come in yes
please richard
i i think that as councilman james has
said i think
we can uh investigate this further um to
look at the viability options uh and
costings as well
bring it back to perhaps not the next
half of all but the harvard board after
that
um to
to see if it's a viable option um i'll
discuss with sean uh an smt
because there may be corporately other
aims
for that site itself
right
thank you
item
64 minute 64.
harbour master to email councillor james
a resume of the harbor along with recent
press release
nobody done it but i would think you're
fairly well up to speed now councillor
james anyway
yeah i've certainly learned a lot in the
last two days
and thank you very much for those who
helped but yes
right thank you
i think we can move on to the next item
which is item
seven am i correct no item for public
contributions nothing that's correct
item five agreement between parts one
and two and there is a part two
i need to put it to the vote that we do
go into part two on that item
yeah just
we don't have the officer here to
present that part i'm not sure if it
should
we'll be doing it
no i was asked if that would be delayed
today yeah absolutely
item
so we don't have to agree that
so we move on item
six which is urgent matters i have none
item seven
interim harbor master we've got a
written report
who's taking it
richard
paul will take this one that's the
interim problem
uh
says ladies and gentlemen jesse you'll
receive my written report and if you're
with your permission i'll i'll uh
embellish that and add a detail where i
can
um you're all aware that this is the uh
port captain labstown is now
resigned and will not be returning uh in
the interim uh mr haste and i have
agreed that i will be acting as that
interim harbour master and um in spite
of any rumors to the country
um i will not be going anywhere uh as
the pilot and i certainly will be
staying on as the harbour master uh for
the port of biddeford until at such time
as mr hayes says that he's fed up with
me um and we've got a proper uh a
harbour master in place so please uh
whatever you may read or hear elsewhere
um while i'm not a volunteer to be bit
of a harbor master because i have
significant commitments elsewhere i am
able and capable i hope to be able to
provide support and or indeed the
harbour master role sufficiently well to
keep it running until a more permanent
solution can be found
i know that you'll let me know if i'm
not doing it to your satisfaction
and please do
i think as we discussed earlier on the
presence of
a harbour employee in the in the harbor
office has actually provided a massive
help one to me as the harbour master
even though i'm distant in torquay we
speak on a daily basis uh to resolve
issues minor administration issues and
or indeed uh harbour mastering issues
and
so far uh i think i think the process is
working reasonably well we've actually
made some really quite significant
progress on harbour mastering items more
which are non
um the written report i rece i i
submitted was incorrect i beg your
pardon i was i was a quarter ahead of
myself there was one commercial movement
in the quarter period that was celtic
forester which arrived on the 25th of
may and disparted on the 27th of may
um my comment reference the
office officer in the harbor office
still stands and i would stand by that
and thank mr puddy for his comments as
well regarding
the the officer that's working there um
a number of vessels in the harbor area
west of the river uh were were moved um
and uh are now being disposed of and
which is what good harbors do to start
getting rid of uh derelict and unsightly
vessels which are a hazard to navigation
and we shall continue to do that
um apple door have been no significant
movements during the reporting period
although the harbour although the um
uh the shipyard is starting to start
looking like a shipyard again there are
people around there are vehicles moving
and occasionally there are small boats
going in and out we're expecting a
rather large ocean going tug in there
next month which i'll be piloting
nothing at yelland
um
no progress report on hro bylaws and and
public forum and that's probably not the
job of an interim harbor martial more
the job of a permanent harbor master
once he's got he or she's got her feet
under the table
uh port security um and forgive me and
please stop me if i start rambling um
the the port of biddeford has to have a
a valid port facilities security plan
which is audited and approved by the
uh department for transport and they are
quite stickly about this they don't
there's no room for any sort of um for
for um maneuver or slackness in this
uh
and
that port facility security plan has to
be delivered or administered by a
qualified port facility security officer
um
my port facilities security officers
qualification cost is not a mouthful
went out of date two years ago
um and richard and i have been trying to
come up with a solution uh whereby we
cover the port
for her responsibilities uh
to the department of transport for
security while the longer term harbor
mastering solution is produced um day
before yesterday uh i spoke to
harbormaster
georgina and forgive me her surname has
just dropped out of my head but the
heart master ilferkum who is a qualified
portfolio security officer
and with the
approval of the dft which was given a
couple of days ago we the port of
biddeford for the time being the next
three or four months will come under the
security auspices of put the port of
ilfricum and there'll be a mutually
beneficial supporting mechanism uh done
that way until the new harbour mastering
regime is installed department of
transport we're happy to approve that um
port of alcohol uh harbour master god
bless her thank you very much to her um
step forward and did that so jeff very
happy to help you update your plan which
i'll be doing in the next few months uh
she'll submit it uh and that's where we
are when it comes to port security um
for the from the um
the uninterest or the interested
onlooker it can sometimes feel a little
bit unwieldy and over complicated but
unfortunately the department of
transport and their port security remit
uh as i said earlier on there is no uh
no flexibility they don't offer any does
it doesn't matter if you're dover london
and felisto or your biddeford or the
small you know mouse hole you still have
to have a port facility security plan
um
yes please i'll draw breath there for a
moment um um
and just finish with my the comments
about the devon audit partnership who uh
orders us in august
um and i've just received the first copy
of the first draft of that uh the audit
report for which mr haste and i will
comment on uh to make sure it's
absolutely correct um
but just to give you as the harbour
board uh reassuring assurance as to what
it is they looked at and what it is we
we've done in the last three months
there are 11 port risk assessments in
place which are due an updated december
uh they've been circulated with the
devon audit partnership and approved
the port marine safety code which is
separate from the port marine port
facilities security
plan the port marine safety code is the
uh the set of documentation by which we
say we're going to run our port um and
it needs it needs an audit every year
and it needs to be inspected every
every year and every three years as we
did last time we send a report to the
mca to say we are compliant
in my opinion we are still compliant
there's always always work to be done on
the port marine safety code
and there is a plan in place with me and
kelly jarman
assisted occasionally by richard to get
keep that plan up to date and by the
time we come back to the next rapalje
master report
that should be done
um
i sit on the uk sorry forgive me i'm i'm
nearly done i sit on the uk harbour
masters council and the uk master
council recently said that the mca had
not received all the uh ports letters of
uh compliance
um and advised every port high and low
in the land to resubmit the letters of
compliance so very shortly uh councillor
james sir um
mr jarman will miss john will be sending
you a uh another letter to sign with my
apologies just to say um uh we are
compliant with the report marine safety
code to resubmit just on the advice of
the uk harbour masters association just
to make sure the port of biddeford is
absolutely tied off and um aligned with
them
um
if anybody's been into the harbor office
bit of hard harbor office kelly's doing
a magnificent job clearing up um there's
going to be a little bit of money you
need to spend on carpets and
working our way through some of the
strata of um
um
stuff that's accumulated in there a lot
of which belongs in uh a museum some of
it some of the ledgers going back 150
years of cargos that have come in and
out of the port which don't belong in
the harbor office they belong in a
museum we'll work our way through to
clean that clear that up nearly there
two more points the pilot boat is going
down to appledore shipyard for her
five-year yearly service survey thank
you pardon on the 4th of october and
certainly any of the councils would like
to come down and see her out of the
water or watch what the shipyard do do
please
contact me and i i'd be very happy to
escort you through looking at what we're
going to do to her we're going to spend
some money because that's what we need
to do unfortunately on boats um
and she's a steelhole boat she needs
money spending on it to keep her
seaworthy and within the coding
requirements
and lastly but but by no means least uh
we are required to have an in-day oil
spill plan which our plan is out of date
um but when it comes to in the list of
priorities between portman safety code
port facilities security plan and or the
basic administration of the harbor or
harbour harbor itself
the oil spill plan comes about fourth in
that there's a plan for us to deal with
that which is likely to be the end of
this year or beginning of next year but
there is a plan to do that
i'm sorry that was a bit long but uh
hopefully in terms of a snapshot of
since i last spoke to you when i was
literally a week in didn't really know
where what i was looking at to have had
three months to look at what the port
does how we are what we need to do i've
got a very clear idea what we need to do
it's all completely within
the scope of myself
uh kelly jarman and assisted by richard
to rectify in the next six months or so
and in my opinion uh i don't think the
harbour board as anything about the way
in which the harbor is being run at the
moment that should keep you awake at
night i hope that's sufficient sorry it
went on a bit long
thank you paul that was very helpful
i realized your paper was nearly as bad
as that which farmers face
um
one question from me before i throw it
open please do you mention the biddeford
harbor office and ledgers of 150 years
old yes
can i ask that councillor christie be
given the opportunity to see them before
they get sent off to a museum somewhere
of course sorry that was really very
much me uh a pining richard and i looked
at them a couple of weeks ago and we
both looked at each other and said these
don't belong in a forgotten office they
belong somewhere i don't you know again
yes of course um so
very much so we'll pass them to as long
as they go to somebody who understands
their value and and can keep look after
them properly i guess
well so long as he sees them he'll he'll
know where to put the money away fair
enough belongs we're told where they go
yes of course can i say something
mr hardaker you wanted to come in
for years i didn't
thinking uh mrs harper mastiff uh i've
been trying for years uh
to find out some of the old
details uh i've got a huge collection of
photographs
i would like to have a look at them if
it was possible to get my records of
today to
go alongside the foe the huge collection
of photographs i've got of uh biddeford
is is that possible sir
chair shall i come in yes i i've got a
number of them here um councillor
christie's had some that were more
specific to
um
the biddeford bridge uh the old dale
bridge part of the british trust but yes
i'm more than happy to meet uh mr
holodecker and kelly on site to uh to
look through some of the old legends
that are there and some of the old books
that we have but certainly councillor
christie um
as you know he's like the custodian of
anything historical so um after we had a
look i'm sure he'd like to look at them
as well thank you paul that's very kind
of you sir i'll make arrangements with
kelly to
come down and have a look at them at
some time
that's it
i think mr puddy would like to come in
yes in the comments buddy
yes i'd like to reiterate the importance
of these documents and um
i think it would be really a good plan
to try and keep them in our community
rather than send them away to another
area
um bearing in mind we have a very active
museum maritime museum in appledore
and also we have the the burton gallery
which is now taking a new approach to
looking at the maritime heritage of our
area so i think it that you know
potentially there will be very valuable
load glue
yeah agreed
fine
um
any comments on the pilot boat we're
just going to live with that
all right
i'll take it that we will get some
estimate of what any repair cost will be
josh will i come in yes um
paul
has already obtained a quote for the
works
that are required for the five year
survey
uh this unfortunately includes even
though the the the boat hasn't done an
awful lot of work um still requires
pulling of the prop shaft for inspection
um but we've had a co quote in that
quote has been checked
um by the in the shipyard of the
approved uh company to to dry dock it
the work where it can be inspected and
the work can be undertaken but uh yes
we've had the quote validated to a
degree and uh
we've given the go ahead
can i ask what the quote was richard
sorry
yeah you can i think for the initial
works in the inspection and paul correct
me it was it was around the six thousand
pound mark that's correct yes
okay thank you
uh and i if i if i just to support mr
haystad unfortunately uh these are um
these items don't aren't negotiable uh
when it comes to surveying the boat um
as as mr hayes said pulling the shaft it
just doesn't um that i tried as hard as
i could to say well the boat's done less
than 40 hours since its last five years
survey surely we don't need to pull this
off but they are the the answer from the
mca is that's what it says on the
five-year survey so you must do it um
which which yes
a bit of a shame
previous history when they
i was on the committee when the last
survey was done
and it was very thorough at that time
i fully realized that
we haven't had as many ships but the
safety of the pilot boat
both captain brown and the cox and
everybody who operated is paramount and
we've just got to live with the fact
of paying whatever whatever charges come
up for the safety of everybody who
operates on the pilot boat
there was a long discussion
uh five years ago about it and people
thought it was a waste of money but
uh
every penny spent is is worthwhile
i think it's fair to say mr hardiker if
it was a hundred pounds it would be
those on the council
but i fully agree with your attitude
thank you sir
yeah mr puddy would like to come in
again yes
um chair and it's probably for poor more
than um
i mean in the past i've operated the
pilot boat and one of the concerns i had
was the the ongoing day-to-day
maintenance of it
um and i wonder if paul you know if
that's now you now have a regular
maintenance program
because uh as mr hardacre points out it
is a pretty important piece of equipment
and the time it's going to go wrong is
when it's um just going over the bar
but i'd like to say one more thing which
is a really important part of actually
having that boat is it provides the
means
for the port authority to patrol the
river and the boat is can be used for
all sorts of very valuable purposes
i might would i allowed to respond
john you're absolutely right 100 um it
is um
unfortunately boats are expensive and uh
boats that aren't used uh tend to uh uh
like old cars if you don't use them you
they they tend to start going wrong in
it by way of maintenance one of the
first things that i did when i arrived
was was um uh we've we've now got a
weekly a monthly in a six monthly
maintenance schedule which is budgeted
for which means that the boat gets its
attention um it's occasionally
um slightly deceptive when you see it
sat down at apple door with bird you
know seagull
doings on it and pizza wrappers on it
but but actually inside the work that's
being done to keep the mechanics of the
boat
um
up to speed because yes absolutely
ultimately at the end of the day uh at
five o'clock on a february morning in
the pitch black it's you know it's my
boat
but it's the boat that's going to come
and get me out of the sea if it comes to
it so um i've got a quite a fairly
strong interest in making sure it's it's
reliable um it's
it's a really difficult one and i'd be
lying if i say that richard hayes and i
don't have this conversation on almost
weekly basis about oh
more money to spend on the pilot boat
come on you know car and sweating its
use to try and make sure it gets used a
bit more is something that i'd like to
try and leave uh to the next harbour
master at least to as some sort of
legacy just see if we can't and any
ideas you might have be very graphic to
talk to
outside the meeting
well train richard or kelly to take it
out for a drive once
[Laughter]
i'm fine thank you
you're aware that mr hayes came pilot
actually came onto the pilot
went up the ladder and came piloting
with me for the last boat um it was very
clear that he didn't want to do it again
quite rightly too it's um i was aware of
it i did hear his comments
um any more on that item
sorry sander
no i think it's just background noise
chair
right we moved to item eight
the accounts
i'll take this one chair
so um this is recorded one
accounts um april may and june
um we've had one shipping as paul
mentioned um
there are you've all got the account
sheet in front of you
can i make sure
is that a yes
yes
yes
so
they look
if you if you look they they're not
normally what we would see after quarter
one um and this uh this is for a number
of reasons really um due to uh paul
oversourcing unfortunately having to
resign through ill health
um and the way his contract was set up
um there is uh a significant sum that's
been returned
to the budget for for
uh pension contributions and also we're
in the interim um for the two months
um that paul hasn't been here
and the the well the three months the
paul hasn't been here there's been a
saving of sixteen thousand so initially
on employees where we would expect to be
on profile budget um there is an
underspend there
all the other lines regarding just on
the harbour are actually
in line
um with profile budget
um the only one that's slightly over but
still under you know is is like i said
the uh
they're all actually in line with the
profile budget so for for the first
quarter it looks well
um
the pilotage side once again
only having one ship and smaller
movements um the salaries are down by
the pilot crew
um
but there may be an adjustment that's
made in quarter three depending if there
is a salary increase
across the board for um
local authority employees
that's been accounted for in the full
year working budget
um
the transport element the the high
number there the full working budget for
um
the pilot boat that includes the
five-year survey which we we budgeted
for this year
and other workers it would be
your prudent
and good business sense to while the
boat is there really to have a good look
at what needs doing
um
not not necessarily you're just nice to
have but the stuff that
you know really needs doing to ensure
that the ship is is safe
and by the sound of things the way
paul's been talking it's just as well i
budgeted for that amount
[Music]
supplies and services
we
that's basically ppe and the pilot vote
survey but also we've got life jackets
that we're going to ensure
um that obviously need checking
regularly uh as other as well as other
certified personal equipment
so
for quarter one it's looking
not how you would normally expect to see
it
um but we're under budget but going
through the year
i think that will come in line
um and we will come in under budget for
the the year if
we continue to have
further shifts
um so we've had one in quarter one and
one quarter two and
i think joe once again regarding the
income and income generation
um an idea that did come from from kelly
as well as you know we
which we've been thinking about is to
have closer relationships with the
agents
with the ballplay suppliers and uh and
see what else we can do within their
restrictions we have for biddeford
harbor so
any questions i'll have your answer
yeah well
thank you when we went sailing i
became aware of
what our staff receive when they're on
these boats
they're not overpaid
that was mrs hardik i do apologize sir
um
any other comments on the accounts
i've got a five-year-old running about
so i'll kick you i think mr puddy would
like to come in chair yes certainly
yeah just to point and i just wondered
um
is it do you um accrue a designated fund
towards the five yearly survey so it
spread across
the long period
chair yes obviously we we
for the budget setting process
uh and this has been enabled us because
paul um as part of the last order that
came through in in january 2020 um the
ongoing maintenance costs and repairs
you know we schedule for the revenue of
of the five-year survey
um so that is budgeted for um we don't
budget uh and accrue it as per say it is
always expected
or on the designated time because it is
a a you know a time when it is required
over five years so
um we are lower that every fifth year
but there is a budget for
um repairs and maintenance
for both the crane and for the pilot
vote
so
thank you
any other questions
no
uh mr chairman sorry the harbour martial
just uh one point could i ask you to
indulge me for 27 seconds so if i can
share my am i allowed to share my screen
uh yeah tom can i do that
um
that's fine i've stopped sharing mine uh
let's hope that this works because i've
got tell me if you can see this
can you see that
not yet
i knew this was gonna happen um i've got
a tire so how do i there we go
um
bear with me for a second two seconds
all right
yeah we can see that
okay right here we go
this is time lapse from from the uh this
lasts for 27 seconds so do bear with me
so this is the um fern caledonia
alongside just as uh you are getting on
board the pilot boat you can see you
watch them
putting the um
uh the hatches on ready to seal before
she goes to sea
look at that beautiful sky
thrusting off see the pilot boat come
past in a moment there she goes
there's a gentleman sat in the back in
the deck chair you're saying doing a
cigar i think
down past the shipyard we're not moving
it's not moving on our screen no no no
last okay i'm i'll try it one more time
tell me if that's working
no just still not moving last i'll let
me without
right one more time here we go
apologies sorry
um
so those are the hatches going on board
um
thrusting away thrusting away off the
jetty you watch the pilot boat come up
the left-hand side you'll see there's a
gentleman smoking a large cigar sat on
the um on the back
past snuffy down past they
[Laughter]
in case you saw a lot of flashing lights
i i always always like to see
photographs i just saw it thank you for
indulging me chair i am i i do this
virtually every trip because it's quite
fun to do so um i'd be very happy to
share that with you so that you can have
a look at it in more detail it's 27
seconds of time-lapse photography but
thank you for indulging me
thank you for
now then let's stop sharing
right
uh we move on now
to ice
yeah john
yeah
mr chair i i was really impressed with
paul's um time lapse and i thought well
maybe sorry paul uh john just stopped
you paul your screen's still sharing i
am just working out
uh beg your pardon thank you sorry yeah
really impressive paul um i just wonder
if this is something that could be put
on the website so that people can just
see what was going on in in torridge
it's already uh on our facebook uh page
the tourish page and it's had over a
thousand views already but that's
something that will be going on we're
we're currently as you know corporately
and coachella james you know that we are
um
we're updating our website and giving
our website a refresh um so that's
something that we want to do and we have
tasks with paul with um taking a video
of the journey in as well as the journey
out
and we certainly will be using these
time lapse videos more often um
even other companies that can do it from
the base of the boat on on the seabed
while they're loading it on a key wall
because i think they'll be really
beneficial and mr bubba you're right
it's really interesting
it's always dark when we come in that's
the problem but yes of course uh yes
it's a good point
okay
um
item
nine
safety management system
i think that's for you again paul
poor you're muted
i'm sorry i i try not to look like an
amateur why you're busy being earnest
until you're away um the the safety
management system um is largely covered
in in my
pla plan when i spoke about the port
risk assessments so the safety
management system is the 11 risk
assessments which govern the activities
within the ports the marine base
activities and then is covered by the
port marine safety code which is a
magnificent 13 chapters of policy
statements and method statements uh how
we do that so that is uh it was audited
by uh me uh uh
to when captain lavish style was imposed
in january uh
kelly and i are going to do another
audit in the in november
to update the progress that we've made
since then
with regards to the safety management
system update the risk assessments and
when i come back to you next time i
should be able to say here are the
pickups from my um as a part of my
report i would like to hope to think i
can record
include a a report on the audit that
we've done but um i'm not going to over
promise at the moment because i'm i'm
not quite sure whether i'm going to be
able to do it uh next by the in time for
the next report being absolutely honest
with you
uh but i will try to i'll try and
endeavor to do that
i think we understand
thank you
any other comments
well i thank you all for your attendance
now you just
oh yeah
mr chairman
yes go on
um
this
zoom
i'm not technically mine
you've been lucky you've got me this
afternoon after a great deal of is there
any chance
of us going back to face-to-face
meetings
at all
i would think unlikely as a council
we've got to have full council and main
committees
as face to face but we don't have to
have these smaller meetings
hey they save us money
be
a lot fun the more convenient
what i did suggest before we got you on
is that young tom vanstone comes out to
your house
and sits down with you and sort of works
through it and
gives you some help and tuition
would that be of help
mr chairman what a brave idea i'll even
give him a cup of tea as well
that's fine norman we can arrange a date
and i'll be there
tom that's very kind of you
okay
any other business
no i'm fine chair thank you
was to buddy anything no thank you very
much
richard
no okay
nothing for me thank you
right well thank you very much gentlemen
i can declare the meeting closed at
3 35.